it's recording
all right we're doing here right okay i
think it's ready this is the world's
first real working lightsaber you guys
ready to make history yeah three two one
yeah it's bright yeah you're gonna peel
some fruit
how are you not impressed with this it's
a real lightsaber i've just got a few
bugs to work out
this is better that's the real deal man
this is a little bit more of a real nice
savory if it's a real lightsaber then
shop this
i mean it's a little short but it's
still impressive right yeah whatever you
want to tell yourself man ready
nice you have to use the force man all
right i'm ready here we go
[Music]
look at that
i mean i think it's still a little short
are you kidding me it's the wall it's
fine it's fine no
it's still growing dude no it's slowing
down though no it's speeding up can't
turn out geez turn it round i'm trying
to turn it off
stop i've got a plan okay we're gonna
take the batteries out right yes i need
a screwdriver okay where's there's one
in the kitchen okay oh how did your
batteries last like 300 years no i'm not
in here are you sure no it's definitely
there we need to get outside okay get
outside
look at the door all right hold on
door's open
one
our friend here has built the lightsaber
i'm sorry
are you filming this yeah i'm under
arrest sir you have the right to remain
silent anything
what is this what is this you had that
the whole time
yeah we can turn it off
yeah yeah why didn't you say something
man
[Music]
come here guys it's a big moment
wait oh do you guys hear that
[Music]
hit that bell if you want to be notified
for all our subscriptions we have a
bunch of great videos coming out this
summer you're not going to want to miss
them
thanks for watching
[Music]